and now last week tonight's work place
of the week this week the National
Football League the NFL is long and
renowned for its concern with the
welfare of all its employees but this
week one group of contractors had some
constructive criticism new allegations
this morning of mistreatment by a group
of Buffalo Bills cheerleaders the
Oakland Raiders and Cincinnati Bengals
are also dealing with wage disputes some
of whom claim they were paid less than
$5 an hour
apparently $5 an hour is just a market
rate for sideline entertainers with one
exception a mascot that is the person
who dresses up in the uniform of an
animal usually gets paid about $25,000 a
year Plus unlike cheerleaders mascots
get benefits enjoy your doctor's visits
and FERPA morphic dolphin humanoid but
while the NFL may not pay cheerleaders
much in money the advice in their
handbook is free and there's plenty of
it from how much to talk to how much to
eat - which feminine hygiene products to
use oh and of course this and had to
submit to a quote jiggle test so their
boss could critique their bodies a
jiggle test because the sight of
quivering excess fat has no place in the
NFL
and in return for all these workplace
indignities the NFL asks cheerleaders to
do a job where they're barely heard
barely seen and have had the only
responsibility in their job title that
of Leaning shears usurped by Jumbotrons
their only remaining responsibilities
serving as human speed bumps for
gargantuan and tight ends and that is
why the NFL is this week's workplace of
the week